martin biron hélène buzzati stéphanie
grammond bonsoir bonsoir alors
vaccination c'est la clé dans tout ça
est hélas le ministre s'est amusé on
peut être étonné donc c'est dans vos
poches matin l'éditorial qui est très
dur ça marche pas du tout le ministre et
pour que chez vous mais ailleurs les
analyses à la télé tu es le ministre
martin ce matin bon y'a pas perdu son
sourire maison qui dit venez tester la
suivait mois au cours des quatre
prochains jours et après vous serez en
mesure de me critiquer mais là il est
trop tôt on est content on vient
mars et avril on va être en bottes 50
avril mais on va être en route 50000 la
moyenne de ces quatre mois là va faire
qu'on va avoir vacciné nos 5.3 millions
de personnes notre défi c'est de vous
prouver de prouver aux québécois dans
les prochains jours que s'il astrazeneca
qui est une bonne nouvelle
sort bien dans les prochains jours non
pour montrer que la machine peut faire
65 70 milles par jour
c'est ce que chouette daniel met
beaucoup de pression tous les matins moi
aussi mais on on y loge je commence avec
vous martine note en bas de page il faut
que les gens acceptent de prendre là ce
troisième cas s'il fallait que la la pac
est engendrée classera zeneca fasse que
les gens n'y avait pas l'examen ou au
pire un problème ouais mais y est les
derniers jours les images des derniers
jours ont fait très mal ou gouvernement
et ceux qui pensaient que ce sera un
long fleuve tranquille puis que cette
opération vaccination là se promènerait
100 heures jusqu'à jusqu'au 24 juin je
penserai avait un peu en couleurs mais
n'empêche qu'il va falloir que ça
s'accélère un peu mais quand on met bout
à bout les chiffres que me donnait le
ministre en fait monsieur paris ce matin
en disant on a déjà reçu deux millions
quelque 2 doses plus 1.4 en avril +1
point 6 en mai et là on nous dit en jeu
ça va être incroyable c'est en finir par
an vers a rendu là mais quand même ça
veut dire que le 1er juin avec toutes
ces doses là on aurait plus de la moitié
de la population de vacciner alors si on
arrive à le faire là accélérer un peu
plus à huiler la machine parce
qu'effectivement il ya du sable dans
l'engrenage
mais peut-être que ça va bien aller il
n'a pas été aidé les gens vont finir par
être vaccinés qu'on va avoir moins peur
des variants que la situation va se
placer je pense que les gens vont
oublier les mauvaises images de la fin
de semaine en autant qu'elle ne serait
pas trop et stéphanie je le disais dans
vos pages notamment ce matin très dure
critique également le minet ce plein
qu'il a besoin de 4 5 jours pour montrer
que la machine va
la voiture va aller plus vite et rapide
du week-end pascal ont montré que le
sable dans l'engrenage
c'est vrai que le québec est en avance
on se réjouit ne sommes par rapport aux
autres provinces ont fait régner faut le
souligner mais quand même
sandoz qui sont restés dans les semaine
dernière ça prouve quand même là quand
on dit qu'on vaccine à peu près à 40
mille doses par jour ça prouve quand
même que ya quelque chose qui est
perfectible
donc c'est une course une course de la
vaccination contre les nouveaux variants
courront le plus vite possible on dit
pas que le gouvernement tout faux mais
si on est capable d'aller encore mieux
en plus perfectionnés du système il faut
le faire et donc moi à ce chapitre le je
me dis il y aura peut-être toujours des
gens qui ne viendront pas à leur
rendez-vous même s'ils l'ont pris et en
tête toujours des gens qui et pourquoi
ne pas aller au devant et avoir un peu
plus de flexibilité dans le système elle
permettre aux gens de venir en fin de
journée si les six autres se sont pas
présentés par exemple aux états unis en
vue d'aider des vaccinateurs qui sont
sortis et qui sont allés offrir les
vaccins pratiquement aux passants pour
s'assurer qu'il y aurait rien qui se
perdrait donc je pense qu'il faut
vraiment envoyé un message pas que
chaque dose est importante et que le
plus vite sera le mieux hélène ce n'est
pas propre qu'au québec parce que par
exemple le globe and mail ce matin sa
grosse manchette c'était qu'il y avait
du retard par tous par rapport aux
données dans les bras mais en fait
et oui il faut souligner le fait que le
québec est en avance a presque
systématiquement sur toutes les autres
provinces alors il faut quand même
tempérer les critiques constater que
somme toute on est ralentie par le
nombre de doses
même si ces cinq mille doses du week end
encore là moi je les remets un peu en
perspective parce que compte tenu qu'on
restait sur un week-end et qu'on en fait
à peu près 50 milles par jour donc cent
mille pour la fin de semaine même 150
mille sons prend les trois jours et ça
veut donc dire une perte et je demande
guillemets parce que ces vaccins n'ont
pas été perdus mais deux qui part comme
5% dans n'importe quelle organisation
de quelle que nature que ce soit il ya
toujours des pertes d incapacité
structurelle comme comme de 10 et
stéphanie des personnes qui ne vont pas
à le reprendre et vous qu'ils changent
d'avis parce qu'on est prévue quels
qu'ils soient
moi personnellement ce sens mais là il
ne m'offusque pas outre mesure dans la
mesure où ces deux zones ne sont pas
perdues je le répète bon mais je reviens
avec mon manager en bas de page l'astra
zeneca martini un test de maintenant
c'est ouvert ou 55 ans et plus il faut
que les gens aillent parce que il ya 320
mille doses d'astrazeneca qui seront
distribués partout au québec sauf en
abitibi faut que les gens y avait
évidemment on peut pas reprocher aux
gens d'avoir des doutes quand la santé
publique et les santé publique
10 55 ans et plus 55 ans et - pardon
allez-y donc pas pour la soirée le cas
attendez le faisait au modern à ces
seules teintes ce domaine
mais ça c'est vrai ça va être très
intéressant de voir comment tout ça va
se dérouler parce que le sans rendez
vous c'est ouvrir une porte le moment
donné c'est ce qu'on a reproché
finalement au gouvernement en fin de
semaine dernière ne pas avoir mis par
exemple sur twitter écoutez on a de la
place pour des dons là on en a des doses
et c'est ce que la france fait là il ya
dvd des vaccinateurs dans les pharmacies
et là quand les gens ne se montrent pas
au rendez-vous il appelle la famille d'à
côté on viens avec ta femme de 40 ans
pas grave vient tant votre vacciner que
chauffer le jsl sont disponibles et dos
un peu ce qu'on a eu au moment on a
reproché le manque de flexibilité
alors voyons voir comment le astrazeneca
va se distribuer je pense que les
experts ont inondé nos ongles dans les
dernières 48 heures pour nous
dire que le risque est très faible alors
ça va être terrible
je vais y aller de même si j'ai les
mêmes couleurs de même vous aussi oui
bon on sera deux on va se donner rendez
vous d'un master non mais non
effectivement au dos mais d'après demain
ce sens dans les prochains jours alors
disons hockey petit mot là dessus sinon
je vais passer un sujet qui passionne
les gens portent choix des courriels
c'est fou ça tombe bien c'est fanny vous
connaissez bien su l'immobilier mais
sinon hélène c'est fanny sur la soirée
des classes à voir ok alors je vous ai
je vous ai montré je voudrais préparer
un petit graphique d'autres graphique
que ce giral sur l'évolution des prix
des maisons un premier ça vient dire
qu'on a mais c'est tout chaud puis on ne
pas jouer le canada nous eux-mêmes place
le canada comme étant le pays où le
marché immobilier et le plus emballé le
alors vous voyez de 150% banques de 250
l'an aura scellé c'est l'année de l on
le mit à 100 alors là on est rendu à
deux fois et demie plus que par rapport
à 2000 mais voyez les autres pays on bat
tout le monde je vous donne des exemples
très concrets pour la pour l'ensemble du
québec prochain tableau d'aller voir les
prix montent montent unifamiliales 27 %
d'augmentation pour l'ensemble du québec
condos 25 pour ça l'osce a augmenté le
plus saint jean sur richelieu
c'est pas des blagues 46 %
d'augmentation pour une unifamiliale et
puis on va on se rapproche de montréal
vous allez voir d'autres chiffres
unifamiliales 33 % d'augmentation à
montréal
c'est sur une année ça et 30 2% pour la
grande région une familiale alors
stéphanie chance avec vous y at il une
fin à tout ça ça fait des années qu'on
prédit que l'immobilier vous revenir sur
terre et puis que ça ne se passe pas
j'ai eu une pause quand même à montréal
pendant plusieurs années
mais là c'est vrai que depuis trop deux
trois ans et c'est très très très fort
et avec la pandémie contre toute attente
c'est ça s'est emballée encore plus
moi je plains les jeunes qui veulent
acheter leur première maison aujourd'hui
parce que des pourcentages c'est beau
mais en chiffres absolus ce que ça donne
c'est pour acheter une maison à montréal
ça prend cent seize mille dollars de
plus que l'année dernière
ça c'est de l'argent si on avait décidé
d'économiser pour ce faire mise le fond
on réalise que tout l'argent qu'on a pu
économiser ben ça vous enfants encore
plus alors que les jeunes se disent mais
qu'est ce que je fais ce que je lance la
serviette ou est ce que j'achète le plus
vite possible pour éviter de me faire
complètement dépassée alors ça risque de
faire en sorte que la que la demande va
s'emballer encore plus on est comme dans
une spirale
et quand on voit le marché qui augmente
de prendre mes % en un an
souvent les gens disent à l'immobilier
c'est du show l'insee de l'abonné oui je
m'excuse mais si ça manque de 32% en un
an ce sapeur descendre aussi de prendre
pour cent ça devienne la spéculation à
un certain point
donc la bulle pourrait de nouveau éclaté
çà pourrait c'est clair qu'il ya des
raisons pour lesquelles les gens se
précipitent 9h20 immobilier lé
télétravail le lève le fait que les gens
ont besoin de plus d'espacé avec la
pandémie
on le voit aussi beaucoup d'envié dans
les zones de villégiature où il ya eu
des explosions incroyable sainte agathe
lefranc blanche et herat mais quand même
il faut bien réaliser le kiwi les taux
d'intérêt sont faibles a lancé ce que
tout ça stimule énormément de le marché
a donné la capacité une capacité d'achat
aux gens mais je pense que des mutants
certains points et elle n est ce qu'il
ya des limites à un point ou parce que
le gouvernement fédéral avait resserré
un peu les règles il ya deux ans je
crois ou l'an dernier enfin bref avait
resserré les règles pour l'action crédit
pour
descendre plus la température est ce que
dans le prochain budget 19 avril on
pourrait voir des mesures pour
restreindre l'accès à la propriété
je ne sais pas je suis pas dans le
secret des dieux c'est pas
nécessairement quelque chose dont on a
beaucoup parlé mais une chose dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure c'est cette idée
de peut-être imposer le bien en capital
sur cette résidence principale et
politiquement à ottawa c'est quelque
chose à laquelle on ne veut pas du tout
touché surtout à en prévision de la
campagne électorale
rappelez vous que la dernière fois il y
avait eu une campagne de désinformation
d'affaires des conservateurs qui accusé
les libéraux d'avoir en arrière-plan le
ce ce projet obscur de taxer la vente de
votre maison et tout ça sur la base de
quoi le fait qu'on avait ajouté une
ligne dans le rapport d'impôt où il
fallait simplement mentionné si oui ou
non on a vendu notre maison personnelle
dans l'année pourquoi on a fait ça c'est
pour éviter de l'évitement pour lutter
contre l'évitement fiscal parce que
certaines personnes habitait dans une
maison qu'ils revendaient à chaque année
et dans le fond c'était une business ils
se faisaient leurs revenus comme ça
ottawa n'a jamais eu l'intention de
taxer le gain en capital
certaines personnes proposent maintenant
cette solution peut-être que ça peut
être intéressant mais il faudrait
prendre en compte d'un certain nombre de
choses très importantes par exemple
l'inflation une résidence persie
principal c'est souvent quelque chose
qu'on conserve sur de très nombreuses
années des décennies
et donc oui on la revendre plus cher 20
ou 30 ans plus tard mais l'inflation est
responsable d'une grande partie de cette
eau valeur donc il faudrait que le
caractère et le projet de retraite pour
beaucoup de gens évidemment et aussi les
modifications apportées à la maison vous
ajouter un étage vous creusez le sous
sol c'est plutôt complexe et je suis pas
certaine en vous pisse de l'effet
modérateur
oui mais par exemple pour aider
les jeunes autrefois on pouvait prendre
des hypothèques sur de plus que 25 15
autres en raison d'un interdit sans
justement pour éviter que les jeunes et
les gens s'endettent mais en même temps
martine si on peut pas en acheter un
pour un jeune c'est pas mieux
oui mais ici à québec c'est à peine s'il
ya eu un débat est en fait on en a un
peu parlé à cause de catherine fournier
qui est députée indépendante s'est elle
a posé des questions et je me raccroche
à ce que disent et stéphanie c'est une
jeune députée sa préoccupation c'était
c'était justement l'accès à la propriété
pour les jeunes mais au gouvernement
c'est on est lettre morte l'action dit
on laisse aller le marché en disant le
ministre des finances a dit c'est parce
que on a essoufflé beaucoup de
liquidités avec l'aco vide ça a aidé à
l'époque le marché gonflé mais le
gouvernement peut bouger a pas un mythe
mesures pour aider les jeunes bon on
verra quand on pense qu'il ya un an et
deux mois
on prévoyait que les prix allaient
baisser en fait les lisent
alors pour ce qu'il faut pas croire les
prévisions toujours merci à vous trois
c'est très gentil d'avoir été là encore
une fois à bientôt
roy
[Musique]
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit